he is uh a leader and best a victor as
they say in the fight song at ann arbor
michigan he's also a heisman trophy
finalist a big ten champion he came back
to school uh he could have left he could
have left to go into the pros but he
fractured his ankle last november and he
wanted to
um give one last go and make the most of
it he said that he would seal his legacy
to win the uh big ten championship after
beating ohio state and he has done all
of that and joining us here in the rich
eisen show from the michigan wolverines
on the mercedes benz vans phone line is
aiden hutchinson how are you sir
i'm doing great rich how you doing i'm
doing better for talking to you man um
what is life like for you walk me
through what it's like to be that big
man on campus aiden
right now uh life's a little bit crazy
i'm in vegas right now uh at the
campbell trophy award and then
and then tomorrow got a 6 a.m flight to
houston
for the lombardi award and then fly out
friday for the heisman
and then um fly out on sunday for the
lot trophy so it's a big award week and
um you know just just trucking through
it right now all right we got to eat
right though right none of this rubber
chicken you know what i mean oh yeah
yeah we're eating good we're eating
great okay just want to make sure no no
chicken at all right that's the nervous
bird according to coach harbaugh no
chicken at all right aidan zero chicken
i actually love chicken but you know i
guess
you know we do we see differently on
that all right all right look to each to
each their own um to what do you owe uh
your 2021 season aiden what do you what
do you owe to to this ascendancy that
you have uh
that you have um uh i guess developed
right here yeah um i mean this this 21
season is uh was just unprecedented
something that
nobody expected
um you know out of all of you know coach
harbaugh's years i think this was the
least
likely for us to uh you know do what
we've done beat ohio state win the big
ten championship
um
and that's what makes it so sweet and
you know being a leader
uh on this team and and being one of
those guys
you know to uh you know to bring
michigan back
i mean it is uh it's so it's so darn
cool and um i'm so grateful to be a part
of this when did you first realize it
was different
um
so really the whole off season it felt
different um energy wise you know we had
a
coach harbaugh brought in a lot of young
defensive coaches
and um
and really in in winter conditioning and
spring ball there was it felt like a
renewed energy in in schenbeckler hall
that that uh you know i really hadn't
felt in in a long time it really
probably i've never felt the kind of
energy this off season and you know that
doesn't that doesn't necessarily equate
to winning ball games but you know it
was good in the off season seeing this
great leadership and just seeing guys
invested in the culture and um you know
as we kind of rolled throughout the
season we kept winning and winning and
um i think that was just really a
testament to all the work that we put in
um in the off season to you know
resetting things yes so much has been
made about mike mcdonald coming from
john harbaugh's staff with the ravens to
get his shot to coordinated defense and
call plays and how that has made a
difference can you can you put a little
bit more meat on those bones
forever oh yeah um i mean coach mcdonald
um
i mean the defense is i feel like that
defense is made for me
and made for me to just produce and you
know he really gives me a lot of freedom
um in that defense to really just be a
ball player and um and and make plays
and i think that's you know part of the
reason why i've been so productive this
season is really just his scheme and his
defense and um he's really just just you
know unleashing the beast it seems like
it's uh unleashed another beast on the
other side in ajabo number 55 in your
program number one in your heart uh
what's it like to to just meet at the
quarterback the two of you
oh it's it's so great it's it's really
uh you know in game it's like
if i'm not getting there you know then
david's david's probably getting there
on the other side so
i mean we have some probably one of
probably the best pass rushing duo in
michigan history um you know just
statistically wise
and
you know it's it's so cool being able to
take to take the feel with him you know
every single week
aiden hutchinson here on the rich eisen
show and has harbaugh been uh different
in any way shape or form do you notice
the difference in the coach the hc
um
you know i think any coaches that's
really winning
winning really big ball games and and
winning big ten championships is going
to be happy um obviously this is really
the happiest i've ever seen him um
just in my whole career um
i mean obviously though but you know
even even from the start i mean he was
uh
he was hell-bent on on getting the right
guys in here getting the right coaches
in the program um in order to you know
have the season that we're having i
think he did such a good job in the
offseason you know just finding the
right pieces you know to put into the
puzzle in order for us to have success
did he come into your to your living
room back in the day did he pay a visit
to you and you did okay
what was that like way back when in
2018 maybe
2018. what was that what was that visit
like
for you it was good it was um
i'm pretty sure that was the only
in-home visit i had you know it came we
had some food um
you know nothing he didn't sleep over
not nothing it happened with nordeen
treatment but um okay you know i uh
we just shared a meal broke bread and
that's pretty much it were you thinking
of going anywhere else because you know
obviously your dad's a legacy there and
um and you talk about legacy you have
now
uh passed him on the all-time sacks list
so
right was there a possibility i uh
not really i mean i i miss you was
always number one for me um you know my
parents went there my sisters
both graduated from there and it's it
was uh i really just i visited some
other schools
um unfortunately i visited ohio state
and michigan state and
um you know it it hurt my soul a little
bit to do that
i can say that now
in in hindsight it felt off right it
felt wrong it felt wrong it felt wrong
it
and the funny thing is when i visited
michigan state i came back and i got so
sick
i lost like 20 pounds in the summer
because of that visit and you know i
mean that just goes to show that you
know michigan state is just poisoned for
the soul you just you know what aidan it
just it's your body rejecting
that that's right it's what it was
your body rejected it you didn't reject
the school your body rejected
the concept and the notion you know what
i'm saying it's just yeah and and i'll
tell you what it's just particularly
pleasing to me that uh that um you know
uh that moment uh serves as a what a
character building moment for the team
that's right eventually like what what
did you take from that
lone loss on the season
aiden yeah um i mean i think
you know just looking back at it um
i think if we hadn't lost that game i
don't know if we'd be if i'd be here
today a big ten champion just because
um having a loss like that were we were
up 30 to 14.
we should have won the game but we
really we lost that game ourselves with
aiden
touchdown taken away i mean you you you
forced us i mean please that was
ridiculous that the big ten ref say you
know what game that was ridiculous that
was
yeah the whole game was just i mean it
seems like we couldn't get a call i mean
and then we said it's a series of events
that was just so unfortunate and we
ended up taking a loss just a very very
tough loss and something that i think
motivated our guys so much and we
realized that you know
if we lose another game we don't have a
chance we we uh we're going to be out of
the playoffs we're going to be out of
the big 10 championship like
i think that was a
eye-opener and a kind of a reality check
for our team
and i think it's something that really
pushed us
to take that next level
aidan hutchinson heisman trophy finalist
from the university of michigan here on
the rich eisen show so coach harbaugh
mentioned after the big ten championship
game it was your idea
to honor
uh
the oxford high school and oxford high
school community um with patch and tate
meer wearing number 42 and put that on
the uniforms is that is that the case
aiden did you help yeah yeah i was uh
um i saw it on social media and it was
something i was talking to my mom
about a bit and she kind of proposed the
idea to me something that we can
commemorate um him and those that lost
their lives in that shooting i thought
that was a great idea so i called coach
and um
he i mean he was on board from the jump
and he had that patch made in the next
20 minutes
so um yeah he was he was all on board
and i thought it was just insane that we
scored
42 points and literally he gave me
goosebumps when i when they when someone
told me that in the fourth quarter so
that you're standing on the sideline and
somebody points the to the scoreboard
and say hey that matches the number of
the patch that you came up with the idea
of of of putting on the uniform
yeah it was just it was insane i got
goosebumps and you know the hair comes
up on the arms a little bit and i mean
that's just
that's
that's god working in a mysterious way
or whatever you think i mean that is
cannot be coincidental
42 also the number that you put up in
the week before it as well so um this
team right now uh when you you do get
back together um
what what do you what do you think here
i mean how are you gonna get together
and say let's finish this thing off we
got house money sure we wanted to beat
ohio state and and be big ten champions
you've achieved that but that's georgia
going to be right there in front of you
um and uh and then maybe either alabama
or or cincinnati uh if so lucky what are
you talking about the whole enchilada
here aidan hutchinson yeah um you know
we all know george is a good ball ball
club um you know their defense is is
obviously one of the best in the country
but you know alabama exposed some of the
some of the chinks in the armor so
that'll be interesting you know with the
offense game plans but um i mean we're
all in um everybody is is all in on this
team um
you know yes we beat ohio state and yes
we won a big ten championship but but i
don't think this group of guys you know
we're not done playing with each other
yet because this team is just so much
fun to play with with the guys and the
chemistry
and um
you know if we go out there and execute
defensively and do our thing i mean i
think
you know we got a great chance of
winning that game and then let's just
talk about you a little bit personally
here aidan uh when you you set the
single season michigan
sac record with a with a sack in the big
ten championship game um what was that
like when you saw your dad after having
that now on your resume
um actually i i broke his record in the
ohio state game right but
the sing his record i'm talking about
there's nobody above you now on that
list oh yeah yeah
yeah no it's it's crazy though um you
know all jokes aside i mean it's
something that i i was dreaming of you
know coming into this season i knew i
had a chance especially you know with
the new defense and my role i knew you
know
opportunity for me to make a lot of
plays and you know seeing him
after that ohio state game and um you
know he made a little joke to me
um you know about me beating the record
um but uh yeah it was just so cool it
must be so weird for him to to you know
you know he was he was at michigan when
he broke the record then he had me
grew up and now he's watching me break
his record so um you know it must be
just so weird for him
i'll tell you what man um
it's it's just amazing to watch you play
it really is and in terms of you know
i'm gonna get emotional here if you
don't mind you know i went to school
there 86 to 90 and your dad was there
when i was there and you know
it makes me all feel old right to see
you wearing your dad's number and
playing
a game i'm like oh my god that's chris
hutchinson's kid
but the way you play also makes me feel
young again
it's the fact it's the truth and that's
what alums feel about college sports
when somebody does what you're doing
with your teammates what you're doing it
makes me feel like i'm back in college
again and i never thought i would really
have that feeling as a father of three
and what i do and it is a beautiful
thing and the way that you and the rest
of your teammates talk about each other
and go about your business and i know i
might be losing listeners and viewers in
certain parts of the state of michigan
right now but in ohio but hopefully
they'll be tuning back in it's a
beautiful thing and i cannot thank you
enough i cannot oh my god that's so cool
i mean that's so awesome that you say
that that's uh
you know i mean it must be just crazy
for you to even be you know seeing the
kind of revival too
it's great because jim was my first
quarterback i want a freshman year he
was my guy my first game that i ever
watched was a fiesta bowl and harbaugh
and michigan lost to nebraska and then
here i am
watching you do what you're doing right
now with cade mcnamara who i got to be
honest he looks a lot like jim playing
the position and
and and and then hassan haskins reviving
a running game and then the rest of the
team playing so well and so terrifically
and i i'm gonna get all you know uh i'm
gonna get all you know emotional seeing
you in new york i mean what if i told
you this last one for you here aiden
what if i told you the day that you
broke your ankle against indiana last
year hey
come back you'll beat ohio state you'll
win the big ten and you're going to be a
heisman finalist and play yourself into
me being the first overall pick of the
nfl draft you would have said what to me
oh my god
i would have said are you kidding me
oh my god i mean i just got a little
goosebumps hearing that just because
you know i mean i went in blind you know
this year you know you don't you don't
know the outcome of anything and you
know if you told me that my junior year
i mean i would just be elated and just
so happy
and so grateful really and um man it's
just this whole season has been so darn
cool and and you know hopefully you know
we got we got more to come okay so you
gotta you got four is this this is a
four suit trip or you're you're any you
know was that what you got yeah it's uh
yeah
it's a lot of suits a lot of
a lot of i brought one here i get a
they made a touch for me at the other
one and then i got a i got a little
special one for the heisman so what do
you got you got anything that i can um
you can
you'll see you'll see oh i got i got a
couple special things in it too so you
know okay tune in oh you're the perfect
person you get a perfect person to ask
this um aidan what did you think of
kenny pickett's fake
slide and run
since you would be one of those people
that might get flagged for 15 if you uh
hit him while he's sliding and he just
showed everybody that he might not slide
if he's trying to slide what'd you think
about that aidan yeah you know it was
cool it was flashy but
you know there are some things in the
game that just do not make sense can i
tell you something rich doesn't make
sense okay how
how a tight end who's who's flexed out
can go and blindside block me and [ __ ]
me
and
it's not a penalty it's not a blind side
block or a chip
because it it's just and then you have
to fake slide we're told to we're told
to to you know to back up when when the
quarterback's about to slide and then he
fakes it in the room for a 60-yard
touchdown
i mean
i i i don't know rich you tell me
well the thing is i don't know how you
would prevent it right like what like if
somebody's if somebody begins to fake
slide that the play's dead right there
the minute that you give yourself up but
what happens if like say uh mccarthy who
is really talented at the position as
well you know with all due respect to
cade you know he he stumbles and some
big ten ref says you were gonna fake
slide and then you're like what the hell
you know what i mean like that's
oh that's interesting that's i mean i'm
always talking about the unintended
consequence trust me with the nfl and
all this sort of stuff but
um that's where i don't know but i would
be like again if i'm mel tucker michigan
state's the next one played kenny
pickett i'm telling everybody don't use
your helmet but go for them i'll deal
with the refs that's what i would say
that's what i would say yeah honestly
you know yeah that's interesting so you
get chipped a lot huh you're getting
chipped you're getting chips i mean i
could you don't know how many times i
got
i've gotten put on my ass a couple times
just from guys i don't see and um i mean
they just blindside block me and then i
get destroyed because i'm not even
looking at them and then
but then it's you know just football
doesn't make a whole lot of sense right
now um just just with a couple calls i
mean it's a little frustrating but
here's the life of a defensive end and
then interestingly enough aiden
hutchinson on the opposite side football
makes total sense right now this is
exactly
what
should be happening you know what i'm
saying you're right you're still right
[Laughter]
all right so i need you to eat right i
need you to avoid las vegas and so much
more okay i need your focus let the man
have fun no no no no no there's there's
more to come right and that's what i
need
more to come there's more to come
there's more to come right this is
exciting so thank you for the call and
just thank you for everything and please
send that to all of your teammates in
the interim and i hope this is the first
of many times we get to chat aidan
i will thanks so much rich right back at
you that's aidan hutchinson right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here